Baltimore erupted in unrest on Monday
April 27th after the funeral of 25-year
old Freddie gray who died in police
custody Maryland's governor declared a
state of emergency and deployed the
National Guard to the streets a citywide
curfew went into effect the following
night to last at least a week scenes of
the unrest including youth rioting and
looting have captured the attention of
news outlets and people around the world
but this story didn't start with
Monday's uprisings or even with the
death of Freddie gray although that
certainly was a catalyst gray was
arrested on April 12th after making eye
contact with a police officer and then
running away
cops dragged him to a police van where
he asked for medical help but didn't get
it the family's lawyer says 80% of gray
spine was severed at the neck while in
police custody he died after a week in
the hospital but Baltimore's anger isn't
just about the death of yet another
young black American at the hands of law
enforcement
it's about being forgotten and being
left with a devastated economy a broken
education system and few options to
articulate that frustration the city of
Baltimore itself is a paradox on the one
hand it's a growing hot spot destination
for Millennials while on the other hand
it's home to almost 1 in 4 people who
live below the poverty line that level
of poverty is due in part to the loss of
100,000 factory jobs between 1950 and
1995 Baltimore also has the highest
incarceration rate in the state of
Maryland and the city has paid about 5.7
million dollars over police brutality
lawsuits between 2011 and September 2014
and then there's Freddie Gray's own
neighborhood of sandtown-winchester
Harlem Park it's the breathing symbol of
the extreme conditions in Baltimore that
frustrate its residents young folks
attics community showing decades old of
anger
frustration for system has failed them I
mean it's bigger than Freddie gray this
is about the social economics of poor
urban America in sandtown three percent
of the total population is in prison
giving it the third highest
incarceration rate in Baltimore
households make on average just over
$24,000 a year and thirty-four percent
of the residents don't have a high
school diploma or a GED pair that up
with a one in five unemployment rate and
the fact that seven percent of the
neighborhood's kids have high levels of
lead in their blood and try asking again
why is Baltimore angry but where does it
go from here
Baltimore's recovery from the damage
caused by the protests won't be easy
parts of the city haven't even been
rebuilt since the 1968 rioting that took
place across the country after Martin
Luther King jr. was assassinated but the
same questions we've asked before are
being asked today why did Freddie gray
have to die or even get arrested for
that matter what will it take for black
men and women in Baltimore and
nationwide to feel safe in their own
neighborhoods and when will those men to
serve and protect serve and protect
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]